thanks to brilliant for supporting this
episode of journey to the macro cosmos
go to brilliant.org microcosmos to learn
how you can take your stem skills
to the next level
[Music]
[Music]
it's not really hard to see how heliozoa
got their name
with their spheroid body and spiky rays
it seems almost impossible to not pick a
name
related to the sun so why not refer back
to the greek god of the sun
helios of course heliozoa aren't exactly
riding golden chariots across the sky
but
they've been similarly difficult to pin
down
and that's partly because we've come to
understand that labeling things as heli
as howa
might not be as meaningful as we once
thought it was
in the 19th century when heliozoa were
first described
the label was thought to apply to just
about any
spiky fresh water organisms that looked
like
spiky freshwater organisms the
similarity in their appearance
suggested a proximity in their
categorization so it made sense
to group them together that has of
course changed in more recent years as
scientists have turned to studies
of organisms dna to revise those early
classification systems so they better
match
genetic relationships so today heliozoa
is less of a specific label and more of
a
description referring to a set of
organisms
that are round with stiff pseudopodia or
axopodia the more technical term for
those spikes
and they are not necessarily closely
related to one another
they just look like it
[Music]
if a helios owens axopodia seem
threatening to you
that's good those stiff spikes aren't
there as decoration
they play an important role when the
helios owens hunt for food
whether that's other protists or even
tiny animals
and you should probably think of them
less as spikes
and more as sticky skewers
after the helios owens prey gets caught
in the axopodia
it is immediately immobilized and stuck
to the adhesive surface
the prey then gets drawn in towards the
heliozone itself
until it is close enough to be engulfed
into a vacuole for further digestion
the central driving life of the
heliosoen is in that central body where
food is consumed and the important
biological molecules that keep the
organism
alive are made and what a fine spherical
body
it is but let's be honest it's the
axopodia that makes a heliozoa so
striking to look at
and for as long as we've been looking at
heliozoa we have wanted to
know more about how those axopodia work
and how they are made after all axopodia
have quite a lot to do
they're not simply stagnant spikes on a
heliozoin
they're an extension of the organism's
cytoplasm
carrying the extrusomes that make their
surface adhesive
and they contract when the organism
needs them to like when they're drawing
in their prey
it's tempting to compare the axopodia to
having just a bunch of
arms but the comparison doesn't do the
axipodia justice
after all it's not like we can retract
and extend our arms out of our bodies at
will
while axopodia are in a sense that
cytoplasm
poking outwards there needs to be
something underlying those extensions to
give them
shape and structure and that something
are hollow filaments
called microtubules made from a protein
called
tubulin you can think of microtubules as
building blocks for eukaryotic cells
though they're
shaped like rods not actual blocks
microtubules
show up in mitotic spindles cilia
flagella and many other pieces of
cellular machinery
and how they're arranged inside an
organism whether they are unicellular or
multicellular
impacts everything from shape to
movement
and heliozoa's axopodia are no different
in the 1960s scientists wanted to
understand
how the microtubules arranged and
rearranged themselves
and how this impacted the heliozoa's
response to changes in the world around
them
to get a much much closer look than we
can do here they used electron
microscopy
which revealed that the microtubules
were arranged
parallel to one another and when they
looked at a cross-section of the
axopodia they found
that the microtubules formed an
interlocking double coil
formation but scientists are rarely
content with just knowing the structure
of a thing
they also wanted to know how that
structure responds to all sorts of
stimuli
in the second half of the 60s louis g
tilney and an assortment of different
collaborators
published a multi-part series of papers
titled
studies on microtubules in heliozoa
we think some selections from the titles
convey the goal
of these studies we have part two the
effect of low temperature on these
structures in the formation and
maintenance of the axopodia
then there's the sequel in part three
the pressure analysis of the role of
these structures in the formation and
maintenance of axopodia and yes
there is a part four titled the effect
of colchicine
in the formation and maintenance of the
axopodia that
is a lot of analysis on the formation
and maintenance of the axopodia
and these experiments helped to not only
see what happens to heliozoa and
changing conditions
they helped our understanding of the
microtubules inside them
for example when the researchers lowered
the temperature of a heliozoin
they found that the organism's axopodia
shortened
until they disappeared a result of the
chemical connections holding the
microtubules breaking down
and the structure depolymerizing and it
was only
around 30 to 45 minutes after the
heliozoa were returned to room
temperature that the microtubules
reassembled
and the axopodia grew back to their
normal length this result
combined with other observations they
made with their other disruptions helped
to solidify the microtubules importance
in the growth and structure of the
axopodia
and provided us with more insight into
the cold sensitivity of microtubules
these experiments were not the end of
the pokken prod and disrupt the axopodia
approach to helios own research
a later study would use what feels
almost a poetic method or at least as
poetic as you can get with a science
experiment and a microbe named after a
sun god
the researchers subjected their
heliosoen to ultraviolet light
watching as the ends of the axopodia
broke down
and shortened or sometimes even broke
off altogether
and yet even then when the ultraviolet
light had passed
the sun and molecules microtubules
were ready to grow once more
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and thank you again to
brilliant for supporting this video
our specialty here at journey to the
micro cosmos is
talking about the micro sun and
molecules of the world but what if you
wanted to learn about a sun that's a bit
more
macro like you know the actual sun
well in brilliant solar energy course
you'll examine the principal methods of
harvesting energy from
sunlight starting from fundamental
physics principles
and by the end of the course you'll be
able to answer practical engineering
questions
surrounding cells material design
and considerations in servicing utility
scale electrical grids
brilliant is built on the principle that
you learn best
while doing and solving in real time
since all of brilliance courses are
interactive you'll get instant feedback
and be able to learn
at your own pace if you're interested in
learning more you can get 20
off an annual premium subscription at
brilliant.org
microcosmos there's a bunch of names on
the screen right now
those are our patreon patrons every one
of those names is a person
who is helping make this show possible
so if you like what we do
they're the people to thank and you can
learn how to become one of them
at patreon.com journey2micro
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss you can check
out jam and germs on instagram
and if you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby